en este vídeo publicado en el sitio web
de unicef Sara quien solía hacer una
niña soldado en África Central cuenta su
historia
se ha reclutado como niños soldado un
flagelo que está lejos de ser un caso
aisladora del sur Nigeria y somalia
decenas de miles de niños son utilizados
en conflictos armados en todo el mundo
niños y niñas a veces muy jóvenes
algunos de tan solo siete años sirven
las fuerzas gubernamentales o los grupos
armados de oposición algunos se unen por
desesperación Pero la mayoría son
secuestrados o reclutados de la fuerza
si hablamos de somalia suelen estar en
zonas controladas por grupos armados a
menudo no tienen elección son tomados
sistemáticamente a veces son las
escuelas coránicas el objetivo son
infiltradas y los niños más o menos
ideologizados
una vez inscritos los niños soldado
pueden luchar pero no solo son espías
mensajeros vigías o cocineros y a veces
se ven reducidos a la esclavitud sexual
si hablamos de niñas a menudo son
violadas y obligadas a casarse a una
edad inimaginable Generalmente son
reclutados más los niños que las niñas
si hablamos de alchebab están en primera
línea
entre 2005 y 2020 se calcula que más de
93.000 niños han sido reclutados en
conflictos armados un fenómeno que
organizaciones no gubernamentales como
unicef intentan combatir en particular
insistiendo en la prevención y la
reinserción de los antiguos niños
soldados